Madison's your eggs oh [ __ ] will last
year we after we did a study abroad to
Italy actually I have some pictures yeah
it does yeah that's real oh my god how
do you name Edison um she's my
ex-girlfriend
Madison's your eggs oh [ __ ]
what how well do you know her she's my
roommate
oh I'm the worst person in the entire
world we broke up a few months ago
we're definitely over each other it's
fine I don't know my god this is not a
good idea I should not be in bed with
you okay like if that's what you want
then that's fine but I really like you
Bridget
I don't having a good time yeah me too
I mean she's already cool girl she'll
she'll be cool she'll be fine right yeah
I don't know yes
yeah
[Music]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] idiot Bridget I've got
Toa oh that's like I work today Jack hey
Matty hey what are you doing here uh I
didn't tell you her I lived no I know I
did you ask somebody where I lived
cuz Jack that's that's crazy okay like
this is over I don't want to get back
together and I think the longer we do
this the it just look what my roommate
[Music]
you can do this okay Bridget hey hey
[Music]
so you hooked up with Jack I was gonna
tell you I was literally about to tell
you I'm so sorry I didn't even know it
was him we had talked about him so much
I know but I've never seen a picture of
him I mean I believe you but nothing you
were trying to hurt me I don't want to
be with him he's way too immature for me
so sorry but it's true it's fine that
you guys hooked up
okay you have my blessing or whatever
he's not my property thank you so much
I'm so sorry I have a really good time
with him
it's just you know next time he comes
over I'll let you know beforehand okay
thank you so much really appreciate it
yeah if you're worthy next time he comes
over
[Music]